[Music]
you know the green screen and blue
screen you know it becomes the
missed covered planet deserted jump
background
[Music]
what happens when the imaginary planet
is already
there
[Music]
the moment you step in the middle of the
volume
you're just you're just there the volume
is the epic sounding name for the
combination of
high resolution led panels imagine
awesome huge tv screens wrapping around
a stage
the physical set design matched to the
panels
and 3d models plopped into an
environment the same way they do
in a video game then it can respond to
camera movement to simulate the real
world
disney pluses the mandalorian a live
action star wars tv show
used this technique my name is charmaine
chan
and i'm a lead compositor at industrial
ida magic
is it physically like confusing being on
on this set oh absolutely i mean the
thing is like you're
you're shooting all day let's say in the
same
exact scene and like you're at that
location it doesn't feel like
it's something fake it just feels like
an extension
of a regular set stage you know you got
to be careful because there are times
where
people don't see where the end of the
stage is and where the leds are
you have like wiley coyote and
roadrunner situations where somebody's
like running into the wall
or something yeah we definitely made
sure that no one's running
in that stage because of that reason
charmaine is credited as part of the
brain bar
the group of visual effects artists that
operated this system
one might adjust models like a rock or a
spaceship
in the panels while another might tweak
live animations
like a burning fire charmaine often
adjusted color
it was funny because it looked very much
like you know back in the days when you
would have
telephone fundraising stuff like on pbs
it was just rolls of people with phones
ready to go
but instead of phones we had computers
in our walkies as mandalorian vfx
supervisor ian milham
tweeted the set crew and brain bar
operating the panels
let them radically change environments
in just a few hours
or beyond set as they launched it
into hyperspace
[Music]
my normal working life is very much
behind a computer
in a dark room somewhere in the corner
now i'm actually
in there with the gaffer
with the prop designers with the set
designers
most people that we would never see
because we're
in the post-production process it was
very
accelerating but sets like this one
weren't just fun for charmaine
they helped to remove creative
roadblocks as a compositor
we're the ones who kind of take all the
renders take all the cg elements and put
them together
to make it look like it's a seamless
integrated photo so think of it as like
advanced photoshop
but for dealing with moving imagery
charmaine worked on this scene in the
last jedi we get this
footage of kylo in front of a green
screen
if you're lucky this green screen will
be evenly lit
with no seams and it's a piece of cake
that's never the scenario spending the
time almost frame by frame making sure
we can remove that
green screen so that we can put kylo on
top of that
removing a green screen is actually
still pretty hard
for one it doesn't work with green
characters
yoda's green
removing one solid color or keying can
look good but you still need detail work
see how these fine branches just
disappear
perspective of the background also
doesn't naturally change
that has to be designed into the final
composite
ditching the green screen and projecting
or playing the image behind the actors
gets you closer but not quite there
[Music]
[Applause]
you can get detail in an illusion of
depth and better light
instead of green screen spilling on the
actor you get blue sky
and red desert actually lighting them
that basic technique has worked in
everything from 2001
to oblivion but you missed the proper
perspective
shift or parallax in the background
since it's just a video playing on a
screen
the volume tackles some of those
problems
you can also adjust light and objects on
the fly
and the reflections actually work
because they are reflecting the other
screens
instead of a green screen which was
especially important for mando
the show's main character his whole
armor
was reflective from head to toe whether
it be his pauldron or his helmet
it was just like you can't avoid
seeing things being reflected
[Music]
so creating this volume where we
literally could close up
the whole thing into one giant circle
and have an environment all across these
screens
we were getting exactly what we wanted
to out of his helmet
the brain bar could focus on details
that made the final product
as seamless as possible which was still
a lot of work
i would go in and whether it be a rock
or a barrel or something i would try to
color correct it to match what was on
the set
but where color correction was more
important was when we're dealing with
the
bigger parts of the set so whether that
be
the dirt on the ground versus the dirt
in our digital scene
and the lighting from the scene affected
the dirt
on the ground so then we would have to
like because we had a blue sky and
suddenly now there's all this blue
on this rock we would have to color
correct the ground and the rock
to also have just as much blue as the
blue that we just introduced
before they started shooting i would
have
five to ten minutes to get that all
lined up and ready to go
i can imagine that there are some
creative breakthroughs
that this makes possible for for your
job what would those be
with this technology i'll be honest i
would
not be mad if i never have to do
a green screen keying or extraction ever
again
now i get to be a person who's doing
the shot and i can help basically
finalize a shot in camera it just makes
it a more
um cohesive
filmmaking process and this puts us
right
in there next to everyone else who's
creating these
shows or films
it was great to talk to charmaine and
learn a little bit about her work and
some of the amazing things that she's
worked on
this video is actually from a sponsor
which is verizon they just turned on 5g
nationwide so with 5g nationwide and in
more and more cities
you get the unprecedented performance a
5g ultra
wide band it's really fast the world's
fastest 5g
you can download an album in a few
seconds it's not just going to change
your phone
it'll change everything i'm guessing
that a lot of creative breakthroughs
will come from it too
so this is the 5g that america has been
waiting for and
it's only from verizon verizon doesn't
directly impact our editorial
but their support makes videos like this
[Music]
possible